depending on the size it takes about
three to five bottles of shampoo to wash
my hair many people might want to view a
real-life Disney Princess but these
ladies have taken it to the next level
their long luscious locks could give
Rapunzel a run for her money
check out these twenty girls and women
who have uninspiring long hair our first
real-life Rapunzel is a little girl with
big Disney Princess energy a few years
ago Charlie was just six years old
Charlie lived in southwest England with
her parents and older sister she had
beautiful long blonde hair in fact it
was over two feet long Charlie loved her
hair but she loved helping people even
more one day she watched a TV show about
kids who are battling cancer she decided
to donate her long hair to make wigs how
could her parents refuse such a sweet
offer she raised money online for an
organization called children with cancer
UK then she chopped it off what a little
hero malgorzata cool chick is a Polish
born English woman with a gorgeous head
of hair she has been growing her locks
out since she was 7 years old she hasn't
even trimmed the ends in years
now in her early 30s malgorzata x' hair
is long enough and thick enough that she
can wear it like a dress she loves
styling her hair in different ways she
also uses a coconut oil mask to help
keep it silky and healthy she posts on
her instagram under the name miss long
hair too weak to handle myself out there
mother well sometimes growing out your
hair isn't a choice that's the case with
young Sophie Field House back in 2014
Sophie made the news for her long hair
she has a genetic disease called
congenital hyperinsulinism it's a very
rare illness the medicine
took to manage it is called diazoxide
and it has a strange side effect it
causes hair to grow really fast so he
decided to embrace the long hair life
while she was on the medicine thankfully
it worked so well she was able to get
off of it we'd love to know if she has
kept her long hair since she stopped
next up is another little girl with a
big heart Kayleigh piscina is a six year
old girl from Los Lunas New Mexico she
first learned about children with cancer
when she was four she wanted to donate
her hair Callie has made it a tradition
to get her hair cut every two years and
donate it
her mother was hesitant because her
curly locks were so pretty she cut off
eight inches the first time in early
2020 Kaylee cut off another ten inches
of her hair for wigs for kids
you go girl Elana kravchenko is known as
the Ukrainian Rapunzel and she has fully
embraced the title she is 34 years old
and she hasn't cut her hair in nearly
three decades Alana's hair now reaches
six feet long it's so long that she
trips over it when she walks but she
says she'll never cut it when she was a
little girl her mother told her feminine
beauty comes from long hair at age five
she decided to never cut it again that
is serious dedication our next Rapunzel
has also not cut her hair in 30 years as
a follower of the Sikh religion
Balvinder does not believe in cutting
her hair now 35 she originally had her
hair trimmed as a kid but she stopped as
she wanted to be more faithful it takes
her 15 minutes just to brush her nearly
five-foot hair to keep her hair healthy
she eats lots of veggies and lots of
protein that is definitely good advice
for anyone with long locks if you think
washing long hair sounds like a pain you
could do what Frankie does Frankie is 33
and hasn't washed her hair since she was
13 she started growing out her hair when
she was 6 and hasn't trimmed it since
her 18th birthday as a little girl she
wanted to have her hair like a fairy
tale character it's actually low
maintenance and her hair looks really
healthy
she said washing it was difficult
because it's impossible to get all the
product out
the first couple of months were itchy
but then the oils in her hair balanced
out
I have magic hair that glows when I sing
the Russian Rapunzel didn't always have
beautiful thick tresses
Anastasia suffered from alopecia when
she was younger
alopecia causes your hair to fall out in
large amounts but a specialist call to
trichologist helped her overcome this
disorder now she is a technologist
herself she's in her early 20s and has
developed products that help combat
alopecia in other people she definitely
has the heart of Rapunzel she says to
keep long locks healthy eat a balanced
diet and use a variety of oils and masks
in your hair olya nazarova has spent the
last 20 years growing out her hair it
now reaches over 90 inches long Aliya is
30 years old and she is from Latvia in
2017 her hair alone weighed four and a
half pounds which she compared to the
weight of her cat her hair even has its
own side of the bed it takes an hour to
comb her hair and a full day to let it
dry her husband Ivan loves her long hair
she also has a YouTube channel where she
offers tips for people with Rapunzel
like locks it can be devastating to get
a bad haircut but now Anshu patel turned
it into a positive thing when she was
sick she had such a bad haircut that she
swore to never cut it again now she is
in the Guinness Book of World Records
for having the longest hair on a
teenager she is 17 and her hair measures
a whopping 6 feet and 3 inches she uses
a homemade oil treatment with some
secret ingredients to keep it looking
healthy
[Music]
and dududu my mother I grew in my head
like this and I said dad I called Lee
Ann Robinson from England had hair that
reached over four feet long when she was
28 she had been growing her hair out
since she was 11 years old
Lee Ann said that she can't leave the
house without people comparing her to
Rapunzel little girls are fascinated by
it women in nightclubs asked to take
pictures with her
we haven't seen an update on the Ann
since 2017 so we're curious to find out
if she has continued to grow it keep
watching to find out about more
record-setting long hair before Anolon
chi patel took the title kato Kawahara
had the longest hair among teenagers
originally Kaito grew out her hair to
hide a scar
it grew to five and a half feet long but
Cato decided to cut her hair when she
turned 18 she wanted a new look before
she started University she loves her
shorter do and she donated her hair for
wigs for cancer patients
she's almost 19 and is doing great
mother says when I was a baby people
tried to cut it they wanted to take it
for themselves this 30 year old Russian
model didn't grow her hair out to be
like Rapunzel it was actually a bet
Darya kuba Nova had her hair down to her
knees when she was a young teenager but
she cut it off a friend told her her
hair would never grow back to that
length ever again Daria was determined
to prove her friend wrong her hair is
now pastor heels Daria has close to 200
thousand followers on Instagram back in
2013 bo Donna made the news for her long
hair by the time she was 8 years old her
hair was already three feet long she was
inspired by Rapunzel and got her mom on
board her mother spends a half an hour
every day combing and braiding her hair
but she said the hardest part is washing
it every 10 days she uses a
strengthening shampoo and a bunch of
conditioners she's now 15 years old and
we can't help but wonder if her hair is
still growing
back in 2017 Monica Shah claimed that
she had the longest hair in all of
Britain and she was probably right no
one else came forward to claim the title
Monica's hair was 63 inches that's over
5 feet Monica who is now 40 hasn't cut
her hair in 17 years she washes it
weekly which takes an hour then she
spends three hours drying it
she also applies a hair oil twice a week
which keeps her locs luscious and shiny
a woman in Zambia has hair almost twice
her height blister theory is around 50
years old she noticed that her long hair
just kept growing rather than cutting it
all the time she decided to embrace her
lops her family and neighbors helped her
keep her hair maintained that way she
doesn't have to spend money going to a
salon blister pits her hair in ponytails
and wraps them on top of her head this
process takes three hours she only uses
vaseline and detergent paste in her hair
to save money today is kind of the
biggest day of my life
our next Rapunzel is Andrea Coulson a 36
year old mother her hair measures in at
over five feet long she often wears her
hair in a braid which takes half an hour
to do she keeps a blog with hair tips
and styles fish oil I know it sounds
gross but you know in capsules it
doesn't bother me at all so I'm taking
that every day Andrea says all the
peanut butter she eats keeps her hair
silky and shiny she trims off the dead
ends regularly and she puts coconut oil
in her hair twice a week she also stays
away from hair dyes and only uses cold
water for rinsing I love sharing videos
and pictures with all of you our next
record holder is Asha Mandela Asha holds
the Guinness record for longest
dreadlocks ashes drugs are an astounding
55 feet long I didn't plan to grow my
locks this long I just started growing
my locks and as time went by I grew in
there so long that she has to carry her
hair in her handbag when she walks Asha
has said that growing out her hair
wasn't about style or trying to be a
princess instead it was a spiritual
journey
now she can't imagine ever cutting off
her
it's a vital part of her Asha has dubbed
herself dreadlocks Rapunzel and it's the
perfect name heavy in terms I guess in
numbers when it's dry it's four and a
half pounds when it's wet it's anywhere
between 12 to 15 pounds Noemi
is a 25 year old woman from Peru with
gorgeous long hair as of June 2019 her
hair was close to eight d long it began
as a joke with some friends on a road
trip but now no Emmys life goal is to
have the longest hair in the world she
wants to be immortalized in the Guinness
Book of World Records
Noemi doesn't have any major routines or
secrets she does braid her hair every
day because it's uncomfortable to wear
it loose I am the lost princess aren't I
for a short time in 2017 a Brill had the
longest hair for a teenager when she was
17 it was just shy of five feet long but
her title is now held by Anolon chi
patel she has something else in common
with an Elan she - a Brill also stopped
cutting her hair after a bad haircut
when she was a kid
she's now 20 and her hair is still
extremely long what record would you
like to break let us know in the
comments thanks for watching give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe see you next time